>> Female Presenter: Good afternoon, everyone.
Authors@Google New York is
pleased to welcome today Dr. Oran Hesterman.
Dr. Hesterman is the president and CEO of
Fair Food
Network.
And he is here today to present his book Fair
Food: Growing a Healthy, Sustainable Food
System for All.
As stated in the bio of his book if you read
on the cover
there, for 15 years Dr. Hesterman has co-led
the
integrated farming systems and WK Kellogg
Foundation
during which time the foundation seeded the
local food
systems movement with 200 million dollars.
In Fair Food
Dr. Hesterman outlines the change that must
be made in
regarding not just how we eat but how food
is grown,
packaged, delivered, marketed, sold and addressed
by
public policy.
Thus outlining the steps we all must take
beyond just eating organic.
Dr. Hesterman.
[Applause]
>> Oran: Thank you very much.
It's very good to be here with
you today.
Thank you for the invitation and for your
interest in this topic.
I'm going to try to -- I think
we have about an hour together.
So I'm going to try to
keep my remarks short enough so we maybe spend
half the time
with me talking a little bit about the book,
what's in it, why I wrote
it, and a little bit about the work we do
at Fair Food Network.
But I want to save about half the time to
hear what you –
what's on your mind, what questions you have,
what you're
thinking about this issue.
So you know if we're going to
create a healthy and sustainable food system
for
everybody, I would say the single -- you're
asking me
before, "what can we do?
What can a person do?"
I would
say the single most important action for somebody
to take
is to make the transformation from conscious
consumer to
engaged citizen.
So what do I mean by that?
So I'm 36
years old.
I'm not 36 years old right now.
Most of you
aren't even there yet, right?
But when I was 36 years
old, I am lying in a hospital bed with such
a severe
flare-up of ulcerative colitis that my digestive
system
stopped functioning altogether.
Lying there with an IV
in my arm being pumped full of prednisone,
the doc comes
and says, "if this inflammation doesn't cool
down by the
end of the week, our only option is surgery."
So
I'm lying there faced with losing my colon
for the rest
of my life.
Couple days later when the doc says, "okay,
we think you can eat something now."
In comes a tray as
I'm lying in bed.
Roast beef, a pile of mashed potatoes
and some big ass piece of cake.
White flour, white sugar
cake.
And I look at this food and I say, "No way.
I
know this is not the food I need to get my
body healthy."
So I politely send the food back pick up the
phone and
call my friend and ask her, "Can you save
my life this week?
Can you
make some brown rice, tofu and steamed greens
and bring
them to me in the hospital?"
So fortunately I got
better.
You know, knock on wood, I'm now healthy as
can
be.
But while I was lying in bed during that week
in the
hospital, I was thinking about how fortunate
I was that I
both knew what I needed to eat to get my body
healthy and
I had the access to what I needed.
And I also thought
about all the people who either don't have
the education
and knowledge or if they have the knowledge,
they simply
don't have the access.
You know, I live in Ann Arbor and
a lot of our work in Fair Food Network is
in Southeast
Michigan in the Detroit area.
Now Detroit might be the
most severe situation of a food desert in
the country
where over half the population in the city
of Detroit,
the 11th largest city in the country, they
don't have
access to fresh food and healthy food.
In fact, since
2007 there's not a single supermarket in the
city of
Detroit -- not one.
But it's a situation you can find in
almost any inner city community in this country
including
parts of New York.
So the question is, "why should we
care about this?"
I mean, all of us lead very busy
lives, right?
And you probably have certain causes that
you care about.
My hope with writing my book and with
visiting with you is that you can think about
moving the
idea of repairing the food system a few notches
higher on
your list.
And you know this is why it's important to
care about it.
One reason why it's important to care
about it.
A few months ago I was in an audience much
like this but a little larger listening to
the executive
vice president of the largest health insurance
company in
the country.
Here's what he says -- he says, "we've
looked at the trends, we've run the numbers,
we've done
the predictions and our numbers tell us by
2018 the cost
of treating obesity related illness in the
United States
will be 345 billion dollars a year."
He says, "when that
happens, it not only bankrupts our company,
it bankrupts
this country."
So why should you care and why do we have
to care?
Because if this happens, if that actually
happens and current trends are taking us there,
I don't
know how many of us will be able to afford
health
insurance.
And the burden of all of us for paying for
health care for those who aren't insured will
be more
than we can bear.
And all that happens in 2018 or
somewhere down the road depending on the predictions
because we're not doing enough today to create
food
environments that enable people to access
the food to
keep them healthy.
You know, you've got a great food
environment here at Google.
I know about that and it's
wonderful.
And the point I make over and over in the
book is that we need to take the health and
vitality that
we gain from living in a healthy food environment
and
make sure that it's not just us; it's everybody.
You
know, there's a lot of, in the story I'm telling
the
what's happening with obesity and diet related
illness
and food access, there's a lot of bad news.
I know that.
But there's actually some good news; really
good news --
I promise you.
Because we really are sitting in a
historic moment right now.
A moment where the rising
tide of diet-related illness and obesity is
being matched
by an up-swell of resources, of ideas, and
of action.
And
awareness on this issue.
We're at a moment where we
actually know what to do about this.
You know many
systems that are broken in our country, we're
not sure
what to do.
How the heck do you reform health care?
Nobody really seems to know what to do about
that.
What
are we going to do about our energy systems?
But about
our food system -- we know what to do.
We know what a
fair food system is and how to create it.
And if there's
one thing you remember from what I'm saying
today, I want you to remember what I mean
by a fair food
system.
It's a system where the food is healthy, good
for our bodies, green, grown in an environmentally
responsible way, fair, nobody is exploited
in that
system.
Everybody gets a piece of the economic pie.
And
affordable.
Everybody has access to the food.
And we
know how to create these systems now.
And the way I know
that is because I can see models and examples
in
practice -- in communities and public policy--
with those
kind of features embedded in them all across
the country.
So we know what to do about this.
That's the good news.
20 years ago we didn't, but now we do.
And you know it's
happening at many levels.
It's happening at the policy
level.
I think about the great work of our first
lady,
Michelle Obama, and her "Let's Move!" initiative
focusing on
this.
And I think of the thousands of farm to school
projects happening now that are supported
with federal
dollars with more federal dollars coming.
It's happening
at the commercial level.
And this is something I want to
spend a little bit of time with because that's
the sector
where you folks live and work.
It's happening --
everything from Whole Foods to the increase
in the number
of farmer's markets around the country.
Tripled since
the mid 90s.
How many of you like going to farmer's
markets?
I mean, I love going to a farmer's market.
Wherever I am -- whether I'm home in Ann Arbor,
or when I
travel around, if I'm there on market day,
that's where I
want to go.
It's like the happiest place in any city I
go.
And they're just exploding.
They're on the
increase.
But it goes beyond farmer's markets and
grocery stores.
I've learned a little bit about how you
do your food service here at Google -- both
here and in
California.
You know, most of the food being sourced
within 150 miles.
A real focus on using food from local
and sustainable sources.
And I think it's great that
your company and other companies are starting
to do this.
And just to give you an idea -- it's starting
to happen
in a lot of places.
You know, Dow Chemical, based in
Midland, Michigan has 43,000 employees around
the globe
and they're focusing on bringing healthier
food to their
employees primarily because they want to get
better
health outcomes.
I mean, they see it as a way to reduce
their cost for health insurance.
So it's smart.
Another
company Bon Appétit Management Company is
another
interesting one to look at.
So they oversee food service
in more than 400 cafeterias in 31 states around
the country.
They serve more than 120 million meals each
year.
And they
have a company-wide goal that they are going
to purchase
20 percent of all of the ingredients that
they use in
those 120 million meals from farms that are
within 150
miles of each cafeteria that are from small,
owner-operated farms or artisan food processors.
And
some of the corporations that they work with
that they're
sourcing food like this Abercrombie and Fitch
in Ohio,
Amazon headquarters in Seattle, Ebay in San
Jose.
And Medtronic headquarters in Minneapolis,
just a few.
It's to me very cool to see
companies like yours and many others starting
to see that
this is not -- yes, it's about what they can
do for
employees.
And employee morale and employee health.
From my perspective it's also about what they're
doing
for the food system.
It goes beyond individual consumers
and it starts to be an institutional practice
which is
what we need to be doing.
You know, it's also happening
at the community level.
And that's kind of a level
nearest and dearest to my heart because of
all my work in
the nonprofit sector in the foundation sector.
Just a few examples here in New York,
in Brooklyn, there's a fantastic project called
Added
Value.
It's a farm in red hook where youngsters are
working -- teenagers from the neighborhood
are working on
about a 3-acre organic farm that was created
on the top
of a ball field.
And they've got a farmer's market there
so that kids are earning money and growing
food.
I think
of Slow Food USA which has its headquarters
right here in
New York and connecting with about 200,000
people around
the country on this issue.
Grow NYC that supports 64
farmer's markets all across the city.
And the most
significant part about Grow NYC is that out
of those 64
markets 49 of them accept what's called EBT
--
electronics benefits transfer.
You'll hear me talk a little bit more about
this.
It's how food stamps are
used now.
So we have now about 44 million people in
this
country receiving food stamps from the government.
It's
the largest single flow of funds in our agriculture
--
through USDA and our agriculture department
-- at the
federal level.
Almost more than 70 cents of every dollar
we spend as a nation on agriculture is spent
on food
stamps.
And Grow NYC is making sure that the
healthy, fresh, locally grown food at farmer's
markets is
also accessible to people who are on food
stamps, who have their EBT card.
So
that's just a few of the examples here in
New York and
there are many, many more.
But in almost every case local
brilliance is really leading the way in this
movement.
And it's all about innovation.
All about innovation.
And I wanted to take just a few minutes -- a
few minutes
to talk to you about my experience with innovation
in
this field in a couple of different ways.
So I'm
probably older than almost everybody here
but
there was a point at which I was younger than
almost
everybody here when I started my career initially
as an
organic farmer.
That sort of transformed into a business
opportunity for me.
So I was living and working on an
organic farm out in Santa Cruz.
It was out at the
University of California in Santa Cruz.
In hindsight it
turned out to be one of the first -- I think
it was the
first-- student organic farm in the country.
And we had 17
acres of land and there was a group of us
-- we were
using French intensive methods of growing
beautiful
organic vegetables.
This was in the early 70s when the
sort of natural food movement was just starting
to be
seen.
It was in its infancy.
No such thing as Whole
Foods or even Trader Joe's.
Nothing.
It was all independently-owned stores,
restaurants that were starting to use organic
food.
And
we started selling some of our food.
It was actually
bartering, right?
So the produce folks from some of
these stores would come up from the Santa
Cruz help us
harvest our squash and lettuce and carrots
in the
morning.
Take them back and sell them in their store.
And we would get credit in their store for
buying the
nuts and seeds and cheese and flour and other
things we
needed at the farms.
That's how we were surviving there.
One day, one of the produce managers from
one of those
stores came up to the farm and while we're
harvesting
they said, "you know, we started having people
walking
into our store - this is 1972-- we've got
people walking into our store asking if they
could buy alfalfa sprouts
but nobody's growing alfalfa sprouts commercially."
Have
any of you grown alfalfa sprouts?
You take alfalfa seeds--.
It's a really healthy
food.
You take alfalfa seeds.
You probably had bean
sprouts at a Chinese restaurant maybe?
So alfalfa sprouts, you take an alfalfa seed,
you sprout it
just for a few days and it's very good source
of many
vitamins.
You could find them in a health food store,
but there were no sprouts being grown commercially.
We took
that on and started growing alfalfa sprouts
in these big jars – big
sort of mayonnaise buckets with screens in
the bottom and delivering them to the
stores or giving them to the stores with our
vegetables.
About a year later, most of the folks who
were working on
that farm left the project to go start farming
in
Arkansas, but I was still a California boy
and I'm not
ready to go to Arkansas.
I'm not ready to live in the Ozarks.
So I inherited that
alfalfa sprouts business.
What that means is I scraped
up the 75 dollars to buy the one bag of alfalfa
seeds that we had on
hand.
I inherited the buckets.
I started growing the
sprouts in the buckets and delivering on the
back of my
bicycle to the three accounts.
By about eight years
later, this was a business that had 20 employees,
delivering sprouts all over northern California,
shipping
into southern California, air shipping some
sprouts to
Chicago.
We were the first alfalfa sprouts in the
Safeway chain of stores.
I was introducing this new
product to people locally in delis to use
on sandwiches,
in restaurants to use on salad bars.
I was introducing
them to the wholesale produce market.
I was introducing them to
the big retail chains.
And we were, by the time I sold
the business at the end of the 70s, we were
growing and
selling nine tons of sprouts a month.
Now, next time
you're in the grocery store, I want you to
go look at
alfalfa sprouts and you're going to see what
the sort of
bulk of 4 ounce package is and then do the
math and
you'll get a sense of what nine tons of sprouts
a month
is.
That was a big operation in those days.
It was very
successful.
I sold it for enough money to go back to
graduate school which I did to earn my Ph.
D. in agronomy
and plant genetics.
Because I was very interested in the
science of all this.
My point in telling you the story
is that whenever people say to me, "you know,
the reason
the food system is like it is and has to stay
like it is
is there are really no options.
There are no options
besides doing it the way we're doing it."
And I say,
"from my experience you're wrong.
There is innovation
available in every field all the time.
And you all know
this.
You live it.
It's part of what has made your
company successful and it's what's going to
propel
success in your company and this your
individual careers.
That's one story of innovation from
my own life in the for-profit sector when
I was younger.
I also want to share with you -- did these
get handed
out?
Yeah.
Let's hand these out so folks can see what
I'm talking about.
I also want to share with you a
project that we're doing right now at the
Fair Food
Network which is the nonprofit organization
that I
founded about two years ago.
So I had spent -- after
being a professor at Michigan state University,
I
had spent another career -- I guess that would
be my
third career -- at Kellogg Foundation.
And at Kellogg
Foundation, I helped them develop a funding
program in
sustainable food and agriculture and was able
to fund
projects all over the country that were looking
at
innovation in the food system trying to embed
some of
these principles I was just talking about
into projects
into policy into practices.
And we were able to fund
about 200 million dollars worth of projects
all over the
country and really kind of seeded this local
food
movement over a period of years.
Now I'm in the
nonprofit sector and one of the signature
programs we're running at Fair Food Network,
my colleague
Anthony here, is our communications and policy
director and is
responsible for our beautiful communications
material.
Lucinda works with us on outreach at the Fair
Food
Network.
And this project, Double Up Food Bucks, the
way it works is that anybody who comes to
a farmer's
market -- participating in the program -- and
right now
there's about 50 of them across the state
of Michigan
with their EBT card remember I talked about
the
electronic benefits card.
They bring their card to a
farmer's market, swipe it at a kiosk to spend
say 20
dollars at the market that day, they will
get an
additional 20 dollars of what we call double
up food buck
tokens.
So they spend 20 and they get 40 dollars worth
of
buying power.
The token can only be spent on Michigan
grown fruits and vegetables.
So what we're doing with
this program is we're encouraging people -- we're
incentivizing them to bring their federal
food assistance
dollars -- right now I talked about the percentage
of the
agricultural budget federally that goes into
this.
If
you look at the numbers, it's about 70 billion
dollars a
year.
So we're spending about 70 billion dollars
a year
of our taxpayer money on food stamps.
I don't argue with
that.
I mean, people are hungry.
We have responsibility to help
them eat.
What we're missing is an opportunity to
innovate and to use that flow of federal funds
to both
encourage low income families to eat healthier.
At the
same time using those exact same dollars to
support local
farmers and a local food economy.
And that's what we're
doing with double up food bucks.
We're demonstrating on
a statewide basis now in Michigan the feasibility
and
effectiveness of these kinds of monetary incentives
to do
those two things at the same time -- eat healthier
food
for your family and for your kids and support
the local
food economy and local agriculture.
So far the program
is going really well.
We're in our second of four years
of this demonstration.
And at the largest farmer's
market in inner city Detroit, again the place
where
there's not a single supermarket, we saw an
increase from
last year -- from 2009 to 2010 -- we saw an
increase of
sales from the EBT card of 368 percent.
So when you let
people know about a program like that and
you have it in
place, people will use it.
And now, part of our work at
Fair Food Network is to share these kinds
of results and
this kind of innovation with our policymakers
in
Washington, D.C. because we believe we can
do a lot
better job with that 70 billion dollars a
year than we're
doing right now.
And that's part of what we'll be
working on over the next couple of years.
So, as I'm
going around talking to people about the book
and what I
wrote about and why I wrote it, some people
consider it
as sort of a celebration of a publication
of a book and I
actually consider it the celebration of the
maturity of a
movement.
You know, I've been at this since the early
70s.
It's been my entire life career in different
forms,
but I'm seeing now an up-swell of concern
and excitement
especially among young people about healthy
food and
sustainability in the food system like I've
never seen.
So I'm really saying, "We're celebrating the
maturity of
a movement.
This is a movement that's coming to
maturity."
It hasn't always been this way.
I think
about a time about 15 years ago.
I'm sitting at a coffee
shop in Atlanta.
It's a Sunday morning and I'm waiting
for a couple of friends to come meet me.
Down the street
comes Gary and Sandy and Gary can't wait to
hand me a
newspaper.
It's the New York Times magazine from that
day.
And it's the -- I look at it and there's an
article
written by an author I'd never read before
-- Michael
Pollan.
We've talked about this beforehand.
So I see some of
you nodding.
So you've been reading Michael Pollan's
work.
Well, this is his first article in New York
Times
magazine.
And it's about genetically modified potatoes
and the farmers that are growing them.
And I thought to
myself, "My God, this issue is now starting
to hit
mainstream."
We had never seen even an article in New
York times about this stuff.
I mean, you see it now, 15
years ago it wasn't there at all.
So I practically inhaled
the article and I'm celebrating in the street,
thinking, "My God, our time is coming."
This issue is finally getting covered by the
press as it
should.
So you can imagine how excited I was a couple
of
years ago when I learned that Bill Moyers
was going to be
interviewing Michael Pollan.
So Bill Moyers, one of the
most esteemed television journalists of our
times,one
of his last episodes of Bill Moyer's Journal
he's
interviewing Michael Pollan.
And Moyers is asking great
questions and Pollan is giving great answers.
It's a great interview and towards
the end, Moyers asks Pollan, "Okay, Michael.
If you now
have the viewers convinced this food thing
is something they
should pay attention to, what's the one thing
you would
tell them to do to make a difference?"
And without missing a
beat, Poland says, "Plant a garden."
And I said to
myself, "Oh shit."
I felt so disappointed at that
moment.
I wasn't disappointed at Michael's answer.
I
mean, I know how important it is to grow gardens.
I grow
a garden myself at my home in Ann Arbor.
I know growing
a garden can change your life.
The more gardens, the better.
I was so disappointed at that moment because
I realized
how many important answers there are to that
question and
how many more voices need to be out responding
to it.
Michael Pollan and Eric Schlosser and the
folks who made
the movie, "Food, Inc."
I have the utmost respect for them.
They have done a great job at pointing out
the problems
and challenges with our current food system.
But we have
to move beyond growing gardens.
We have to take the next
step which is -- the next step in finding
solutions --
not just mapping out problems.
And my belief is that
next step is this shift from conscious consumer
to
engaged citizen.
And that's why I wrote Fair Food to
help be part of taking that next step.
You know, I wrote
this book for several kinds of people.
I wrote it for
folks who lead busy lives and might just have
a couple of
hours a week that they can spend on making
better choices in
their homes, in their communities, in their
families.
I
also wrote it for people who, now all over
the country, are
getting so excited about this work that they're
putting some of
their passion into it.
I mean, that they're really
focusing on this because this book is a resource
coming
from 40 years of experience in the field.
I also wrote
it for policymakers so we can get better public
policy.
Public policy to make sure everybody has access
to
healthy food and policy that helps farmers
reduce their
toxic chemical load on the environment and
save our
precious soil.
And I wrote it from all the different
perspectives that I've had in my life.
You know, farmer,
sprouts businessman, agronomist, university
professor
foundation program director, foundation executive.
I
don't know about you -- I don't know how many
times
you're going to change your jobs and your
career.
I
never thought I'd change jobs this many times.
In
hindsight it's been great, because it's brought
so many
different perspectives into this work.
So I just want to
end my comments and really encourage you to
let me know
what you're thinking and any questions you
have.
I just
want to end with another story about a time,
around 25
years ago, when a group of engaged citizens
changed a
system that seemed hopeless.
Many people tell me, "How
the heck can you think about changing a food
system and
agricultural system that's so big and so entrenched?"
In
1988, you could not see a single scientist
predicting the
fall of the Berlin wall.
But one year later that's
exactly what happened.
It surprised everybody.
But I
think about all the activists in East Germany
struggling under
a system that was strangling them, a system
that wanted
to change.
And then in 1989, literally those same people
picking up hammers and chisels and start banging
against a wall.
We'll never know which brick came out to
make that wall fall down, but when it came
down, it
changed the world.
For those in my generation, who lived
through that, it absolutely changed the world.
The Cold
War Ended almost overnight.
Shifted geopolitics.
In the
same way, I think about food systems activists
many of
whom I have met and supported over time all
across this
country -- farmers, chefs, students, teachers,
moms,
dads, journalists, business people -- each
of them
working in their own way to challenge a food
system that
is not working well for us right now.
Just as with the
Berlin Wall, we will never know which innovation,
which
new model is the one that brings us to a tipping
point,
but it will happen sooner or later.
I wrote my book so
it could happen sooner and not later.
And I really hope
that you will take the opportunity to read
it, to learn
from it, and to ask questions about it.
Because this is
an ongoing process for all of us.
It's the system that's
most important for all of us.
It's a system on which our
life depends.
If we don't get our food system right, I
would say anything else we're doing is less
important, if
important at all.
It's a system we have to get right.
So now let me open it up and see what's on
your mind and
what questions you might have.
Yes?
.
>>Male #1: Okay.
So I actually have two questions.
The first
one is, "How do you define healthy food?
Because I feel that
most people -- that even if they want to eat
healthy, they don't know what's healthy with
so many sources of information"
>>Oran: So like, when we talk about in
our Double Up Food Bucks program we're talking
about creating what we're calling healthy
food
incentive.
And you are right.
There is so
much information; it's hard to read through
it
all.
But there is very little contradiction
that eating more fresh fruits and vegetables
in
your diet is good.
That very few of us are
eating the amount that's recommended by USDA.
And if you look at our low income communities,
you're lucky to find a lot of folks who are
eating more than one or two servings a day.
So
we are really focusing on fruits and vegetables
as the component of a healthy diet in our
work.
>> Male #1: And the second question is actually
continued to your answer.
So if you suggest
fruit and vegetables, do you also recommend
adding the incentive for keeping the animals
safe?
Like the environmental reasons of
growing animals or eating them.
>> Oran: So I'm not sure if you're asking
me
about the idea of vegetarianism or the idea
of
how to sustainably raise animals.
>>Male #1: I mean, I believe it goes
together -- being vegetarian is helping the
environment and also keeping you healthy.
>> Oran: So I've -- I mean, I've not seen
a
lot of -- as a scientist now -- I've not seen
lot of data that says vegetarianism is required
to be healthy, right?
At the same time we know
that, in general, in our society -- our western
culture -- we're eating way too much meat.
As
an agronomist, which is the way I look at
the
world the most, there are places where our
natural ecology is much better suited for
animal agriculture than for crop agriculture.
In one sense, ruminant animals are pretty
miraculous.
All the animals that have multiple
stomachs because they can digest cellulose.
We
can't.
Single stomach animals can't.
And
there are places where producing grass, which
is
mostly cellulose, it's got nutrients in it
but
it's mostly cellulose -- where producing grass
is the absolute best ecological plan.
And so,
my feeling is, on those kinds of acreages,
we're actually better off producing animals
than we are trying to produce crops.
We're
going to be able to produce systems where
the
nutrients are recycled.
I'm actually a
believer in integrating crops and livestock
into agriculture but doing it in a way that's
more agriculturally sensitive.
Thank you for
the questions.
>> Male #2: So over here you speak about taking
us from conscious consumers into engaged
citizens but you're speaking to the choir
here.
What about reaching other people even to the
point of even being conscious consumers.
There's a lot of people out there -- again,
lives are busy or they're misinformed, a lot
of
bad information out there, a lot of marketing
touting vitamins and this sort of stuff instead
of actual real food.
How can we get people to be
concerned and understand that this is good
for the
environment; it's good for their health and
it's also most cost effective?
>> Oran: When I say move from conscious
consumer to engaged citizen, I don't assume
that everybody are conscious consumers yet.
I mean, I know that.
The point I'm trying to
make is that the frame that we -- the way
we
think about food is primarily a frame that
is -- it's a relationship between me and my
plate.
Me and my refrigerator.
Or you know at
the farthest outreach, maybe me and the grocery
store.
And what I'm trying to do is actually shift
our
frame of reference to understand that when
we think
of food -- it's sort of like when we think
about the health care system, we actually
don't
usually think about our own personal doctor.
And when we think about what it's going to
take
to reform the health care system, none of
us
think choosing different a doctor is going
to do
anything to reform health care.
So what I'm
trying to do is move us along in our thought
process around food where when we think about
food,
we're not only thinking about "my relationship
with food and the plate."
We're thinking about
the consequences of my actions, all along
the
system.
And when you think about that then,
you know, if somebody is going to take, if
I -- if a legislator is going to take the
right
stand on farm bill legislation, I don't really
care what they eat, tell you the truth on
a
personal level.
What I care is about the
actions they're taking to make our food system
healthier and more sustainable.
Thank you for
the question.
>> Male #3: It seems like there's a lot of,
you
know, great grass roots movements in terms
of
local farms and co-ops producing organic and
sustainable fruits and veggies, but it seems
like the major shift that needs to happen
is to
do this at scale so it's economically viable
so
so we can price those at competitive rates
to
factory farm produce.
To your knowledge, is there any sort of example
out there,
of a farm that's out there doing this to a
grade
scale to bring this into economic viability.
>>Oran: Yeah.
So first of all, I want us to
challenge our assumptions that locally produced
organic food is more expensive.
Study just
came out of Vermont.
Probably the study was
actually done last year, but it was just
published.
Group of students went out and
looked at -- you know did good statistics
with it.
They looked at the price of vegetables and
fruits at farmer's markets and at the grocery
stores and supermarkets in the same
communities.
And, for non-organic fruits and
vegetables, there was very little significant
difference.
There was some difference in
specific items, but there wasn't much
difference.
For organic, the difference
between supermarket and farmer's market was
percent with the farmer's market being 38
percent lower than the supermarket.
So, you
know, we have to challenge our assumptions.
There's a lot of information out there about,
"oh, yeah -- local produce and farmer's
market -- all this stuff is so expensive,
it's only
for the elite."
The experience actually, when you look
at the evidence, is not so much.
That's sort of
on the one hand.
In terms of the example you
asked for.
I think about friend of mine, Fred Kirschenmann,
who's farming in North Dakota, he's farming
3100 acres of organic grains, seeds, and
livestock.
And you know, if that's not scale,
I'm not sure what is.
So it's, you know, it
has already gone beyond small scale.
And the
question of affordability -- my belief is
the
question of affordability comes down not just
to scaling an individual farm but scaling
a
system.
Where -- we need to be -- we know the
demand for locally grown organic and
sustainably raised food is increasing.
We know
that.
And I've worked enough with farmers to
know they're good business people.
And if they
recognize this demand as real, credible,
stable, they will shift their practices.
This
is where institutional purchasing can come
in,
because companies -- institutions like schools,
hospitals, correctional facilities -- can
actually create contracts to purchase local
and
organic and sustainable food.
And then farmers
have something that's actually -- a contract
that's bankable to borrow money to get to
scale
up.
One of the missing pieces we have now is
called the regional food infrastructure where
you have an infrastructure where 47 percent
of all
retail grocery in this country is controlled
by
four companies.
And when that happens the
entire distribution system has been vertically
integrated with those companies.
And we need
to establish a more regional food
infrastructure so that each individual farmer
doesn't bear the responsibility to find the
individual consumer to connect with, but
there's actually a way to aggregate and
distribute.
So some of the things we're
working on.
Some of the activists you talk about in
your organization are working not just on
the
individual level but that kind of aggregation.
>> Male #3: Thank you.
>> Oran: Thank you.
>> Male #4: My question was actually very
similar to the previous one, but I can sort
of
go off with that.
In terms of the subsidies --
the government subsidies for larger farms
and
stuff like that.
I see that as a pretty large
hurdle for a smaller farm to overcome like
because of the economic incentive behind that
government subsidy.
So what you're sort of
alluding to is this shift, right?
From
government subsidy to sort of a privatized
system like companies investing in farms.
Do
you -- how do you see that -- what's the
incentive for that farm that was getting the
subsidy for corn or something like that
shifting to a totally different model.
Maybe
they've already invested in that kind of
equipment.
Is there a system out there to help
them make that transition or is that still
sort
of gray area.
>> Oran: Well, you know as you talk about
that wouldn't it be great if we decided.
I mean, we're
a democracy.
We get to decide how we spend our
tax money in the perfect world.
What if we
decided rather than spending our 5 to 8 billion
dollars a year in subsidy money on just
supporting ten percent of the largest farmers
in this country growing five crops that we
know
there's surpluses of.
What if we decided we
would use some of that money to help farmers
transition to a kind of agriculture that we're
talking about.
A more regional scale
agriculture producing a more diversity of
crops
doing it in environmentally friendly way.
There's no reason why we can't do that.
I
don't advocate getting rid of subsidies
actually.
I think that, you know, I think
about -- wasn't too long ago that we had
political leaders on both sides of the aisle
talk about these companies that were too big
to
fail, right?
And a lot of money went into
companies that we thought were too big to
fail.
Well, rather than too big to fail, I say our
food system is too important to fail.
And it's
failing a lot of us right now.
In fact, if you
scratched the surface from an environmental
perspective from a perspective of how farm
workers are treated and live, this system
is
failing most of us right now.
So there is
nothing wrong in my view in a democracy for
us
to decide that we need to intervene with
resources of any kind into a sector that's
too
important to fail.
We're just doing it in the
wrong way.
We need to do more of what you're
talking about.
The ideas you have about how to
help farmers transition to a more reasonable
and sustainable kind of production.
>> Male #4: Just a follow up.
Is that more of
like a community outreach in a marketing issue
as well.
Sort of reaching out to farmers on a
local level or is that something that is
lobbying territory?
I mean.
[cell phone rings in background]
>> Oran: I mean, listen it's always going
to
be lobbying territory, because you got a lot
of
vested interest in agribusiness to have things
the way they are.
So let me give you an
example.
Over the last two years the Natural
Resource Conservation Service, which is an
agency of USDA, decided because, you know,
we
have -- we have a new scene at USDA with
president Obama and Secretary Vilsack and
Deputy Secretary Merrigan--
they're thinking very innovatively.
So they
come up with this plan to use some of our
federal conservation dollars to support the
building of what's called High Tunnels or
Hoop
Houses so in northern climates like here,
local
food is great right now.
It will be great till
about Thanksgiving time, right?
And then from
December through May or so, there's not much
there.
But there are great technologies that
have been developed that -- they're called
High
Tunnels.
Just big plastic.
Might be the
length of this room, literally a hoop with
greenhouse grade plastic over it.
And there
are ways to extend the growing season without
any exogenous source of energy.
So you don't
have to heat them.
The reradiation from the
soil takes care of that.
There's ways to grow
crops in there.
So the USDA is now giving grants --
cost share grants -- to farmers all across
the
country, in the northern part of the country,
to build these hoop houses.
I think that's
great use of our government funding.
It's
extending the growing season.
It's helping to
create some of this more regional
infrastructure for production.
I just think we
need more innovation like that in our policies.
>> Male #4: Thank you.
>> Oran: Thank you.
>> Male #5: Hi.
>>Oran: Hi
>> Male #5: So I was listening to this article
or this story on NPR a month back.
Somebody
was criticizing the local and slow food movement.
I don't remember his name, unfortunately,
but
realizing that this transition wouldn't take
place overnight, I'm wondering if there's
any validity to the argument that the guy
was making that there's not enough
local farmers producing food to feed everybody.
Do you know if there's any truth to that,
like if we were all to switch right now, would
there be enough on the supply side to meet
the demand?
>> Oran: Well, I mean, not tomorrow there
wouldn't be, but again, my experience working
directly with farmers.
I spent a good 15 years
working in extension in Michigan where I was
directly working with farmers and extension
agents
throughout the state.
And I got to know
farmers.
I was farming myself when I was
younger.
Farmers are good business people.
If
there's a demand there, they'll figure out
how
to fill it.
If we try -- if we just said,
"Could we make the switch tomorrow?"
Absolutely not.
But if we said to ourselves,
"Is there a vision for what our future food
system needs to look like so it's
environmentally healthy, it's healthy for
our
communities, it's healthy economically, and
then start moving towards that with policy
and
practice.
Absolutely, there's no reason why we
can't.
And I don't advocate for a wholesale
switch.
But right now, we have not -- about 98
percent of our food system is highly
concentrated highly specialized highly
globalized and about two percent of it is
the
kind of system that we're talking about -- more
localized, more diverse, more environmentally
sound.
You know, I would be pleased as punch
if, within my lifetime we saw a shift from
percent to 20 percent.
That would be huge.
It
would change the landscape of food and
agriculture.
So, when people bring up
arguments about how, "Well, we can't even
start
to make the change because you can't do it
percent."
I think it's a spurious argument.
I
think it's a deflection and I think we ought
to
dismiss it and say, "Fine, maybe we can't
do
100%, but I bet you we can do 20."
>> Male #5: Thank you.
>> Oran: Thank you.
Emily?
>> Female #1: So my question is, if we are
all to
become engaged citizens, say we all go back
to our
desks and decide to do something.
What -- this
sounds like a pointed question but I promise
you it's not -- what are
the two or three things we can do.
Is it to write to a
local legislator and say, "Support these changes
in the farm bill?"
Is it to volunteer in Red Hook at their garden?
What
is it exactly we can do today or next week
or next weekend or whatever?
What are the things
we can actually look into to start doing as
we are inspired
by your book and your work.
>> Oran: You know what I say is that it's
important to start where you are.
And that's
why I would never say, "Everybody should do
this or this or this."
I would say that if
you're a parent and you have youngsters in
school and you care about the food that they're
eating and being fed in school, that's where
you ought to engage.
You should start getting
together with other parents.
And learning
about how the school food service works.
Where
they're sourcing their food.
And try to make a
few small changes.
Start small.
If you're a college
student, I would say the place to start would
be getting in touch with the Real Food
Challenge which is working to shift 20 percent
of the 5 billion dollars that are college
university cafeterias are spending nationwide.
If you live in an area that is rapidly
urbanizing, --so I'm talking about people
who
live in suburbs--rapidly urbanizing.
I say, look
into farmland preservation policy.
There's
some examples in the book where that's
happening and how to do it.
You've got great
opportunities right here in New York, as Emily
says, to volunteer with organizations.
To spend
your time and money supporting organizations.
They are all over this city.
This city is rich
with organizations that are working to help
make the kind of change we're talking about
here.
And they all need volunteers.
They all
need financial support.
So there's no lack of
those kinds of opportunities.
And many
directories.
And there's a directory in the
back of my book.
And we're right now
developing our online directory at our website
so that organizations that are not listed
in
the book -- it's in the chapter ten of the
book--
where I list all these organizations but that
want people to know about them can
self-populate this directory that I'm building
on this website.
So people can find each
other.
Something else you are uniquely
qualified to do because you live in New York
and that is you have a senator, Senator Gillibrand
who really cares about these issues.
She
is on the senate agricultural committee and
is
going to be one of the people who is helping
consider the reauthorization of the Farm Bill
which is the place where the subsidies happen.
The places where these Hoop House resources
happen.
The place where our food stamp
expenditures happen.
So one thing everybody
can definitely do is let your own Senator
Gillibrand know that you care about these
issues and
you want to support her to support the kinds
of
policies that we're talking about and that
I'm writing about.
So these
are a few things people can do here.
>> Female #1: And I just have one more question.
Just because I think it's such a great program,
the
Double Up Food Bucks.
After the four years demonstration that you're
doing now in Michigan, are there plans to
expand that to area like New York or D.C.,
or Philly, or
places.
>> Oran: Right now there are some other
programs.
There's something happening in
Philly.
There's something in New York; it's called
Health Bucks.
It's
something different.
We are working now
partnering with organizations all over the
country that are supporting these programs.
And we are doing an nationwide
evaluation and creating what we saying is
a policy
education process.
So there will be some
lobbying involved, but it's mostly education.
And our intention is that when the next farm
bill is reauthorized, we want to bring some
federal dollars flowing into this
kind of incentive work so it is not only being
financed by nonprofit money.
So tell your
Senator Gillibrand that you think healthy
food
incentives are a great idea and you want her
to
support them in the next farm bill.
That's a
very specific thing you can do and something
she can help with.
>> Female #1: Thank you.
>> Oran: Thank you.
>> Female #2: [inaudible question]
>> Female #2: The healthy food incentives
-- so is
that an educational component?
Because I do
feel like lower income people fill that healthy
food is just for wealthy people.
And farmer's
markets are for wealthy people.
So is there
that educational component that no, it is
affordable and using your dollars there can
go a long way.
>> Oran: Absolutely.
I am not at all a
believer in, "if you build it, they will come."
I'm sorry Anthony had to leave.
He had to take
a train back to DC, but he has really been
working hard with communications.
So our
communications around this includes direct
mail, very bright and colorful engaging
postcards.
To every person who is receiving
food stamps in Detroit, Flint, Grand Rapids
and
Lansing, Michigan.
The four biggest city in the
state, three times during the summer telling
them about the program and how to access it.
We
have radio running in those places.
We have
billboards, this summer it will be 50 billboards,
all up over Detroit and other areas
telling people about it.
We're doing bus signs.
And
in addition we're working in a more grass
roots
way.
We actually hired people in those
communities, working with churches, working
barbers and beauticians to really get the
word out about
this program.
The one assumption that I hear
you say that I would challenge, from our own
research, is that folks in these low income
communities don't understand what healthy
food
is.
They really do.
>>Female #2: No, I don't assume they don't
understand.
I just think that they might not
think that it's accessible.
>> Oran: They know it's not accessible.
That's the issue.
We've done the focus group
work.
We've done the interview work.
Most
people in our low income communities of color
understand that lack of access to healthy
fresh
food is, in essence, a social justice issue.
They see it as nutritional red lining.
That's
what I call it.
A generation ago we had red
lining in terms of home mortgages, right?
They
were literally like mortgage banks would draw
red lines around communities that they would
not lend to.
And it was almost always low
income communities of color.
And that's one
reason why home ownership was much lower there.
That's an illegal practice.
You can't do that
anymore.
But from my perspective we have, in
essence, nutritional red lining.
We have whole
vast areas in our inner cities where
conventional food retail is basically said,
"we're out of here."
And we got to do
something about that.
It's not to our own
benefit to let that happen.
But we have --
you're right -- we have to let people know
about this program and we're doing it in every
way we know how and every way we can afford.
>> Female #2: And one more question -- is
local
more sustainable or seasonal more of a
sustainable food?
>> Oran: Well, if you think about it, they
go
together.
Right?
Because if you're going to
eat local, you're going to be eating seasonal.
So in some respects, if you think more about
eating seasonally, it is automatically going
to
to drive toward eating food that's produced
more in the area where you're living.
Thank
you.
>> Female #3: That's it.
That's all we have time
for.
Thank you for coming today.
>> Oran: Thank you.
[Applause]